si voy a estar espacio este momento se
realizan y consejo nacional electoral
esta audiencia pública nacionales
consejeros del órgano comicial están
proclamando poco a poco los distintos
resultados en principio de los
asambleístas y finalmente se hará
oficial el resultado para el binomio
presidencial aseguró minutos también en
el candidato de yahir pérez a línea
entre durante su caminata es momento de
levantarse y dejar el todo señala en
cuanto a la programación de los
resultados electorales señala el y que
se debe llegar alguien del pueblo es una
referencia que le insiste y que existe
un fraude electoral y debe ser una
persona del pueblo a su juicio quien
debe llegar a la presidencia de igual
forma ha dicho que él recuperaría
500.000 votos aproximadamente ante la
presentación de miles de actas de
inconsistencias de votos tal y como él
ha insistido en este aumento también
continúa la presentación de los
resultados de lo que sí está sucediendo
en este momento es una movilización
nacional que viene caminando desde el
sur del país y poco a poco se acerca
en este momento se ubica a 3 horas
aproximadamente de la ciudad de quito
para eso también se espera que el
próximo marcada ayer nadie concentración
no sólo de movimientos indígenas sino
también de grupos de trabajadores
profesionales en las inmediaciones del
concejo nacional electoral